good afternoon everybody I'm Jocelyn
lamento news eights medical reporter
your moderator for this symposium now
over the years I've had the privilege of
having a front row seat at Yale School
of Medicine watching some of the very
best and the brightest and medical
science develop breakthrough research
and treatment then educating you on
those various subjects I've learned a
great deal from the best and the
brightest it hasn't been easy to
interview them to be quite honest to get
that to the simple terms to get it to
the point where people at home can
understand but it's such important
information that it is challenging for
me because obviously I'm not a scientist
but I have learned a lot from them and I
love the fact that I have that that
privilege to come here and learn from
them and then past that some very
important research information to all of
the folks at home who really need to
know what's going on here at the Yale
School of Medicine we are living longer
thanks to what is evolved in medicine
but that has also led to complex issues
such as coping with multiple chronic
conditions and the increasing number of
people being diagnosed at Alzheimer's
disease have done us so many stories and
on Alzheimer's lately today you will
hear from leading researchers on Aging
and how their work will directly impact
you and your loved ones and just a few
housekeeping reminders just want to
remind everybody that we gave you the
index cards so that you can jot down a
question for the Q&A which will occur
immediately following the last speaker
we will also have a break after the
second speaker a ten-minute break now it
is my pleasure to introduce to you our
first presenter dr. Mary
Tonetta is the Gladys Phillips crowfoot
professor of medicine and epidemiology
at Yale School of Medicine and chief of
the section of geriatrics she was the
first investigator to identify that
older adults at risk for falling an
injury could be identified that Falls
and injuries were associated with a
range
serious adverse outcomes and that
multifactorial risk reduction strategies
were effective as well as cost-effective
her current research focus is on
clinical decision making for older
adults in the face of multiple health
conditions her subject when one person
has many diseases please welcome with
dr. Mary
Jannetty thank you it is really
wonderful to be here and I thank you
very much our special guests who been
here with us and very happy to to be
able to be with you so I want to start
with who my favorite adult is no this is
my favorite adult he is my father 91
year old miss he had just climbed up
1200 feet that's overlooking Lake
Superior going up was great coming down
not so much but I also wanted to talk
tell you a story about mrs. s is an 84
year old woman who has multiple chronic
conditions including high blood pressure
she previously had a heart attack heart
failure many of the most common chronic
conditions that older adults face every
day she had multiple of them she also
not eight typically for people of her
age with multiple chronic conditions
takes many medications coumadin a blood
thinner for her atrial fibrillation
three different blood pressure
medications that also help her heart
failure statin for her heart two
medications for her diabetes and an SSRI
for her depression again not terribly
atypical for the millions of older
adults in the United States so Miss
Smith and mrs. s and her doctor we're
really facing many of the same questions
that we face every day they sat down
were wondering are these medications
causing any harm
we know medications have many good
effects
we also know they have harmful effects
given the number that she's taking what
kind of harm might be happening that
we're not aware of second of all are
these medications helping what matters
most to her and third of all the most
important question that we ultimately
want to be able to answer what is the
best combination of medications for mrs.
s that provides her benefit without harm
if at all possible so the title of the
today was good past present and future
so I'm going to take you way to the past
to the 17th century when I first came to
you and it's important to bear in mind
the today's approach to disease really
did evolve in the 17th century when the
evolving technologies of that time
included for those of you who are
historians such groundbreaking
technologies stethoscopes and
microscopes were for the very first time
we were able to understand some of the
pathology underlying the conditions that
people faced were able to relate the
symptoms and impairments that they had
with these pathologies and as humans
we'd love to create categories so we
started creating disease categories
during the 17th century as we moved in
the 17th century to the 20th century
these advances in our understanding of
the pathology were match our
understanding and capabilities in areas
such as surgery and pharmacology and for
those botanists in the audience will
recognize this is a foxglove one of the
very earliest medications digitalis and
so we were able to diagnose and treat
diseases based on our understanding of
the pathology and we evolved the model
of disease approach to healthcare which
still dominates our medical
establishment today and has been highly
successful and is one of the many
reasons why people are living longer but
it's also important to bear in mind when
that disease approach evolved from the
17th to the 20th century
the average life expectancy was in the
40s as opposed to the 80s that we see
today
second of all almost all health
encounters were for acute injury such as
portrayed in this picture or for acute
illness for which people either
recovered or they died there were very
few people with chronic conditions and
they essentially nobody who had multiple
simultaneous conditions as we evolved
that approach to disease against it has
been highly successful but it's
important to bear in mind what mrs. s
who reflects the patient of the 21st
century multiple chronic conditions many
many medications and importantly as I
will tell you vary in what matters most
to them so going back to that first
question are any of her medications
causing her harm as physicians we are
taught to above all do no harm and two
sets of studies that we've recently
completed here that look at that look at
that issue are we causing harm to people
like mrs. s the first study was the
effective anti hypertensive blood
pressure medications in older adults
with multiple chronic conditions we know
from a ray of very well-designed
clinical trials where people are
randomized to either receive the
treatment or not that older adults do
have benefit from blood pressure
lowering medications fewer strokes fewer
heart attacks less heart failure but
it's also important to bear in mind that
these were healthy older adults that
almost to a study older adults with
multiple chronic conditions who are the
more typical older adult were not
included in these trials so we don't
know if those benefits for healthy older
adults are also the same in people like
mrs. s and also importantly is there are
some emerging evidence of perhaps
increased risk of fall injuries and so
what we did we studied a representative
sample of older adults throughout the
United States who are over 65 years of
old age who had hypertension average age
80
two thirds 66% had three or more chronic
conditions very different than the
people in the clinical trials but very
very much like the people we see in the
clinic every single day and we by
looking at the number of blood pressure
medications and the doses were able to
divide people into those who essentially
had no antihypertensive medications for
a range of reasons
those that took one or two are those
that took three or more and as you can
see 14% because we do a pretty good job
in this country of treating hypertension
there's only 14% who took no medications
55% about half two are one or two and
31% well three and ten who took three or
more blood blood pressure medications
and basically what we did we know that
those who take medications are different
than those that don't
so accounting for all the factors that
we know of that may make that may make
people who take medications different
than those that do or those who take
more different than those who take less
accounting for all of those factors what
we found was comparing to those people
who took no anti hypertensive
medications those that took one and two
had no effect no decrease in the
likelihood of having a stroke or a heart
attack in the three years of follow-up
nor those who took three or more very
different from what we found in the
clinical trials but what we did find is
that again people who took no blood
pressure medications adjusting for all
those factors making them look more
alike 40% increased risk in a series
fall injuries such as a hip fracture or
a traumatic brain injury with one to two
medications and by almost a 30 percent
increase in very serious injuries for
three or more medications interestingly
enough there was a decreased risk in
death one of the things were postulating
perhaps it doesn't decrease the
occurrence of a cardiovascular event but
maybe improves the mortality for those
who have an event and it's an area that
we're still exploring but what we do
summarize is that in this population
of real older adults if you will the
larger amounts of antihypertensive
medications seem to be associated with a
decreased risk of death but an increased
risk of very very serious injuries such
as hip fractures and head injuries and
at least in our population no effect on
cardiovascular events are perhaps only a
modest decrease compared to particularly
in strokes compared to what we see in
the randomized control trials no single
study particularly the observational
studies where we didn't randomize people
tell us the whole story and I don't want
to take a message to be that blood
pressure medications don't work but the
implications are that we need to look
further and not assume that what we see
in healthy people are the same if people
with multiple chronic conditions and it
may be perhaps that they do have
different effective treatments and we
need to look at the effect in this
population
it may help cardiovascular events such
as stroke or MI but certainly at the
risk of an increased fall injury and it
really raised for us the question is how
common is this trade-off one condition
better one condition worse in people
with older adults with the treatments
that we give them so with the help of
Jonathan Laura gonpa who's in the
audience who is now a third year medical
student when he was a first year medical
student worked with me on this study of
what we call therapeutic competition and
what that means is treatment of one
disease
it helps treatment of other disease it
hurts in inherently in multiple chronic
conditions and treatments we have trade
offs that we face we help one condition
we heard another and we were just
curious how common is this in our
population of older adults who take
multiple medications so we went back to
that large randomized a representative
sample of older adults throughout the
United States and looked at the 26 most
commonly recommended classes of
medication for the 14 most common
chronic conditions that older adults
have and asked the very simple question
how often did a medication for one
condition potentially harm another
condition and to identify harm we looked
into the matter
literature for evidence of medication
harmonic condition and based on a
relatively systematic review of the
literature for adverse medications in
another condition we found that in this
representative sample of older adults
thirty-six percent over one and three
took at least one medication that helped
one of their conditions but potentially
hurt another twenty percent one out of
five took two or more and 12% took three
over one in ten people took three
medications that potentially could have
harmed one of their conditions again we
don't know that they caused harm this
was the potential telling us we need to
look further to see how often actual
harm occurs and the implications again
isn't quite common that a third of our
population we are prescribing and is
based on disease guidelines that drive
decision-making in healthcare
potentially causing harm to our people
unintentionally meaning that we probably
need to start looking at medications and
what's what what people should be on in
a different way than it currently
currently do it but it also begs the
question if it helps one condition but
hurts another are we treating what
matters most to people so that was
another set of questions that our group
did and Terry free who is my colleague
also at the program and aging and
intersection has also been a world
leader on looking at trying to address
the question of helping medicate using
medications that help what matters most
and we looked at three different studies
that address this question the first was
the direct trade-off in older adults
again went back to hypertension high
blood pressure serious fall injury two
of the conditions that mrs. s has one
out of three people over the age of 65
are at risk for a serious fall injury
for a whole range of reasons and have
high blood pressure this is not a
theoretical or rare trade-off it's an
incredibly common one as you remember we
found that there was a potential
increased risk of serious volleying
with control of blood pressure so we
went out to Greater New Haven area and
identified a hundred and twenty-five
people who had both fall risk as well as
high blood pressure gave them the
evidence the best evidence we have of
how much likely they are to decrease
their chance of a stroke or heart attack
with good blood pressure control with
blood pressure medications versus the
best evidence we have for the likelihood
that we were going to increase their
chance of a serious fall injury so such
as a hip fracture and we were quite
surprised to find exactly half of the
people faced with that trade-off would
say it was more important for them to
avoid the stroke or heart attacks over
they were willing to have a risk of fall
injury or the medication effects such as
dizziness or strokes to business or
fatigue to avoid a stroke or a heart
attack but the other half said was more
important for them to avoid having a
fall injury again we expected people to
really prioritize strokes and and MI
prevention but people were 50/50 almost
equally split again implying that older
adults with multiple chronic conditions
vary in what matters most to them we
cannot as physicians identify what we
should be recommending to our parents
our patients we need to get from them
what's most important to them but it
also begs the question it's really kind
of stupid I mean would you rather have a
stroke or a hip fracture I mean it's you
know it's a little bit of a ridiculous
question so we went back and thought
about it again well wait a second people
with multiple chronic conditions how do
we really compare these treatments to
really answer the question have we
caused benefit or have we caused harm so
we thought about it is there something
such as universe what we call universal
health outcomes are there health
outcomes that are really meaningful to
patients that really matter to patients
that all conditions exert their effect
on so that we could use these universal
health outcomes rather than the
individual outcomes such as stroke or
heart attack and our individuals able to
prioritize when faced with that
trade-off among these universal outcomes
and if so can we use these Universal
outcomes to make decisions about
benefits and harms and so dr. Freid has
really taken the lead on this area and
indeed by asking a whole range of older
adults throughout New Haven really we're
able to really get it down to three
areas and I suspect it's not a surprise
to anybody in this audience people want
to be as functional as possible and that
could be at those daily activities such
as getting here today social activities
cognitive activities but people want to
be functional and they want to be as
free as symptoms as possible such as
fatigue or pain and they want to live as
long as possible
survival so essentially we can take
almost every possible health outcome and
put it into one of these three
categories so it makes it much more
simpler than trying to compare a hip
fracture versus a stroke if we can
compare function symptoms and survival
but that will only work if these chronic
conditions really do affect these
Universal outcomes so that was the next
study we did again going back to that
big sample in the community we looked at
five common chronic conditions heart
failure chronic obstructive lung disease
osteoarthritis depression and dementia
and again asked the question if you
account for all the other factors that
affect daily functioning activities of
daily living bathing dressing shopping
using the phone using transportation if
you account for all of the other factors
and if you come for all the effect of
all the other diseases here do these
individual five diseases affect these
outcomes and what we found is all five
of them independently and very
significantly accounted for changes in
people's ability to carry out their
daily activities we found that arthritis
lung disease depression and heart
failure all affected symptoms only the
dementia did not affect symptoms which
is really what you would expect
and finally chronic lung disease
dementia depression and heart failure
all increase the likelihood that people
would die so again what we were able to
show in this study is that these these
chronic conditions did exert their
effect on these Universal outcomes so
perhaps these are the outcomes that we
should be thinking about in deciding
whether a treatment is really effective
or not but the next question we need to
address is
well then can individuals prioritize if
there really is a trade-off if we can't
have it all we all want to be as
functional as possible it's free of
symptoms and live as long as possible
but what if we can't can people
prioritize so that we can make the
decisions that are going to affect what
matters most to them so dr. Freda and
her group asked again at large in three
different studies in the Greater New
Haven area asked older adults - if you
had to choose rank order the priorities
among symptoms function and survival or
death and they were able to do this and
this was the findings at least in four
Greater New Haven and this was all three
of the studies combined difference in
each of the three studies but 42 percent
thought function was most important 32
percent thought pain and other symptoms
were most important 27 prioritized
survival again people vary and what's
most important to them and we have to
figure out how to incorporate that into
the recommendations that we make and the
research that we do so again people do
think in terms of these Universal
outcomes they are able to agree on a few
outcomes they are able to articulate
their priorities and they do vary and
what matters most to them so finally it
brings us to the future and in a group
in a study that that dr. Allure and
McAfee and I are now doing and again a
very large data set what we call the
health outcomes with medications in the
elderly study we are basically taking
all of those most common chronic
conditions that mrs. s had taking all of
the medications that she's taking and
trying to say
can we identify using these universal
health outcomes can we identify which
combination of these medications are
most likely to give her benefit in the
outcome that's most important to her and
which are least likely to give her harm
and doctor allure did this nice little
schematic for me and if anybody can tell
in the audience that what that means you
get a gold star I certainly can but I'll
translate it for you what we are
planning to do is to identify those
outcomes of symptoms function and
survival take into account all those
defect of all the chronic conditions
look at the effect of all the other
factors that affect individuals health
in these areas and those all those
medications and try to identify again
singles for benefit versus harm so that
we can say you don't need to take
fourteen medications we are going to
find for you your own personal pill that
is the combination of medications that
are best for you that obviously is is
very very much in the future we have a
very very very long way to go dr. Hodes
is going to have to give us a lot more
money to get there but that is
definitely where those of us here at the
pepper Center are going in terms of
trying to identify what works in
clinical decision-making with chronic
disease I just want to end by thanking
dr. hoteis and the National Incident
aging that supported all of this work I
talked about today a particular thanks
to the older adults in Greater New Haven
who have just been quite generous in
their times participating in all of our
studies and the wonderful people at the
program on Aging some of whom who were
brave enough to come for the picture but
all of those who were not as well thank
you